bonsoir il avait pour cette nouvelle
session d'information voilà ce tout
d'abord ce qu'on peut retenir en ce
vendredi 15 mai cous course de france de
l'américaine au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bryan coquard
et thomas boudât ont posé pour la promo
deuxième année leur nom au palmarès de
cette épreuve robert pirès maraîcher bio
installé à magny les hameaux a livré ses
premiers clients une concrétisation pour
cet ancien salarié de l'industrie
reconverti agriculteurs et puis un
festival de théâtre amateur c'est en
tenant moins jusqu'au 24 mai à la salle
de la tour de voisins-le-bretonneux et
nous en parlons dans quelques instants
avec nos invités mais donc sport à
présent la coupe de france à
l'américaine était programmée ce
mercredi sur la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la compétition s'est disputée avec des
sprints intermédiaires avec des équipes
composées de deux coureurs dans la
catégorie élite ce sombre et yann coca
arrêts thomas boudât de la team europcar
qui ont raflé la première place le
binôme a devancé deux trois tours le duo
de larmes et air jordan levasseur et
madame un trauma et n'inscrivent
journaliste amical et demi d'euros a
rencontré bryan coquard
new ceric bryan coquard qui vient de
remporter la coupe de france de
l'américaine trois mois après son titre
de champion du monde sur la même
discipline alors bryan coquard est-ce
que c'était une victoire facile y'a pas
y'a pas de victoire facile
c'est sûr qu'on en a fait le show n'a
fait ce spectacle on a pris plaisir fo
n'était pas dans des conditions
ils sont ordinaires avec thomas moi je
suis un des quatre jours de dunkerque on
était en stage avec l'équipe de france
l'a donc c'était beau là bas c'était une
course d'entraînement on va dire mais
bon on a bon c'est on a pris plaisir on
s'est bien amusé vous avez dû plus
heureuse un pur et simple vraiment sur
cette compétition où vous en avez gardé
un petit peu sous le pied on n'a pas
trop garder donc voilà on en a vu
beaucoup je crois on doit gagner avec
deux ou trois tours d'avancé mais on a
on ne va pas garder en avril n'était pas
faux fond mais
on s'est fait plaisir et ce qu'on aime
on essaie c'est faire la bagarre on est
des compétiteurs donc ce titre
on a pris un sac un petit matelas on va
dire la voix lorsque l on risque quand
même gagné les trois tours d'avancé un
extrait de l'interview que vous pouvez
retrouver dans son intégralité lundi
dans le service sport présentée par
michael et demi d'euros après la coupe
de france de l'américaine le vélodrome
de saint quentin vibrera une nouvelle
fois au rythme du cyclisme avec les
championnats d'île de france une
compétition programmée ce week-end qui
réunira des sportifs de l'équipe de
france comme grégory baugé et michael
d'almeida ou 110 claire
environnement maintenant installé depuis
le mois de février à magny les hameaux
le maraîcher robert pires a effectué sa
première livraison mercredi pour la map
mme annick oise le panier et des hameaux
cet ancien employé dans l'industrie a
choisi de changer de profession il ya
quatre ans et bien ce mercredi il a
déposé 19 paniers voilà mon nez voyez
c'est une première qui a plutôt bien
fonctionné on va justement écouter
robert pirès c'était donc ce mercredi au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
les premières salades
beaucoup de verdure des de la roquette
des épinards et les premiers chou-rave
verra dit aussi et les navettes et les
navettes printemps c'est émouvant il ya
quelque chose de
d'émouvant dans cette dans cette
première distribution
parce que les légumes sont là parce
qu'ils sont arrivés il avait même
plusieurs semaines d'avancé avec avec la
chaleur et je suis très content de
pouvoir pouvoir fournir 1 un beau panier
pour pour cette première distribution
aux amapiens de manille et châteaux
forts voilà donc un maraîcher heureux
qu'on pourra retrouver régulièrement à
magny les hameaux et puis cette
incroyable découverte faite par les
pompiers des yvelines après l'incendié
d'un pavillon aux clayes-sous-bois le
pavillon est partie en flammes pendant
le week-end du 8 mai et dans les faux
plafonds les pompiers ont mis la main
sur près de cent vingt mille euros en
liquide le propriétaire de la maison
absent au moment des faits a expliqué
aux enquêteurs qu'il s'agissait de ces
économies des économies maintenant
envolés en fumée car les billets ont été
retrouvés à demi calciné voilà pour la
petite histoire et on va changer de
registre on va parler théâtre avec que
nos invités et un festival qui se
déroule en ce moment et jusqu'au 24 mai
à la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour en parler en
plateau michel sautreau bonsoir bonsoir
les présidentes animatrice du club john
théâtre et puis deux de vos jeunes
animateurs timothée baisse bonsoir et
jérémy à camille bonsoir alors j'ai dit
le club jeune théâtre était en
représentation jusqu'au 24 mai en tout
cas pour ce week-end et le week-end
prochain la salle de la tour il ya cinq
pièces qui seront présentées
5 et le style des pièces on sent que
c'est plutôt comique des pièces comiques
moderne
pour enfants pour adultes est joué par
les jeunes alors ce sont des jeunes au
club soda d'autres c'est un club de
jeunes on écoute les jeunes il participe
à la mise en scène il faut beaucoup de 8
ans à 18 ans les anciens reviennent pour
écouter les jeunes
du travail qu'ils font les anciens
comment se fait le choix des pièces par
exemple à vous présenter oscar de claude
magnier dont c'est qu'on connaît sur les
faits c'est un choix fait par les
acteurs eux mêmes et les animateurs qui
ont voulu monter cette pièce voilà le
reste bas c'est un peu comme le demande
suivant la médiathèque saint-exupéry
m'avait demandé de participer à l'heure
du conte avait sur la friandise donc
j'ai choisi une pièce sur la friandise
je me suis bien en rapport avec l'auteur
je suis toujours en rapport avec les
auteurs alors écoutez les animateurs de
ce club jeune théâtre comment vous vous
participez à ce à ce festival vous jouez
dans les pièces qu'elle quelle pièce
montée non moi je joue parce j'ai joué
auparavant j'étais
donc j'étais un élève j'ai joué quand
j'étais petit en primaire dans des
pièces est donc là maintenant j'anime
jénine des cours de post année vous
animez une des pièces qui sera jouée
pendant qu'ils soient joués ce soir
qu'est laquelle alors c'est donc le
cadavre du studio 23 qui est donc écrit
par
un jeune c'est écrit par un ancien
animateur afin une ancienne jeunes du
club de théâtre qui se spécialise donc
dans le terne et qui écrit et des par
son frère c'est eux qui ont écrit cette
pièce dont le cadavre du studio 23 ça
parle de quoi bah c'est un petit polar
en faire de bons semble
donc il ya eu donc la découverte d'un
cas grave serein sur un studio de cinéma
woods est donc il ya une enquête qui est
menée par deux commissaires commissaire
et son adjointe et donc on a voilà c'est
ça qu'est ce qui vous a plu dans cette
pièce bah c'est sous les yeux ce côté
soit il ya peu qu'elle peut voir un peu
polar on a mis une mise en scène assez
particulière bah si vous venez ce soir
pourrait voir c'est on a utilisé à
chaque fois qu'un côté de la scène nos
qu'une moitié de la scène pour le
commissariat et une autre moitié pour le
studio du sénat donc c'est vraiment
particulier et c'est bien
jérémy alors vous dans ce festival est
ce que vous jouez dans une pièce où est
ce que vous en ai bien comme thimoté
j'ai joué déjà depuis depuis au moins 6
7 ans je pense mais je joue encore moi
cette année on a joué hier s'est plutôt
bien passé on en a tous trouvé on rejoue
encore
la semaine prochaine vous êtes dans
quelle pièce oscar de claude magnier
avec parliez tout à l'heure parce qu'on
se connaît surtout le film d'edouard
molinaro qui dirait que cette pièce avec
louis de funès là il ya patouiller vient
pas le minerai sur scène non mais qu'est
ce qui vous a plu justement cette pièce
oscar eh bien elle je la trouve vraiment
sympathique parce que déjà elle et elle
est très drôle j'ai trouvé et
elle est assez intéressante parce qu'on
voit c'est assez intéressant de voir la
personnalité qui sait travailler de des
gens des personnages qu'on doit jouer du
coup ça fait sympathique à jouer mais
qu'est-ce qui joue le rôle de louis de
funès mois
vous avez vu le film oui bien sûr pour
s'en inspirer de voix
après c'est une interprétation chacun a
son interprétation du texte qui est
écrit par claude magnier donc on ne fait
pas exactement la même chose que de
funès a fait dans chaque situation mais
on sentait un peu inspiré c'est sûr
c'est pas une pièce facile à monter je
présume il faut beaucoup de riz non il
faut il faut du rythme il faut que tout
aille vite il faut que les transitions
soit toujours rapide je suis que
qu'acteur dans cette pièce
c'est michel ainsi que deux autres
de d'autres aides qui ont animateurs
voilà qui ont monté cette pièce
mais c'est sûr que les jeunes sont
beaucoup écouté justement comment on
monte une pièce comme oscar est une
pièce que vous que les gens connaissent
en tout cas pourquoi ont vu le film pour
redonner à la fois ce rythme à la fois
vaut pas que ça soit ressemblant mais
forcément
quand il ya des personnages aussi c'est
l'interprétation des jeunes on leur
donne le texte à lire et puis il ils
parlent ils donnent leurs émotions et
dix commandants et ses vols le jouer et
c'est vrai que moi si je manque une
séance revient ça déjà changé vers
l'insertion des jeunes qui s'approprie
la pelle justement par exemple ce qu'est
ce qui est assez intéressant dans le
club jeunes têtes c'est qu'on voit des
anciens qui sont venus sur apprendre à
faire du théâtre au sein de votre club
qui deviennent à la fois des animateurs
qui peuvent aussi devenir des auteurs
des résidents et s'est avéré le mais ça
veut dire qu'il ya une véritable volonté
aussi de transmission comme c'est
exactement oui j'essaye de trouver
justement à d'intéresser les jeunes non
seulement au théâtre à la poésie
puisqu'on va aussi de la poésie est
aussi de les intéresser à la vie du club
et de l'association pour qu'ils en
prennent une part eux-mêmes qu'ils
disent ce qu'ils pensent des foyers 6,3
du tout ce que j'ai ce que j'ai envie de
dire ce que je ferais mais je les écoute
il faut les écouter parce qu'ils sont
très lisse voilà qu'est ce qui vous a
donné l'envié vous tous les de devenir
animateur c'est la fois le rôle d'oncle
envie de transmettre ou
l'envi le bas moi je voyais je voyais
toujours des animateurs des jeunes comme
ça de 18 20 ans qui anime et qui nous
faisait faire des petits jeux des bus
pour qu'on
apprenne les bases du théâtre et qui
faisait un peu la mise en scène et moi
j'aimais bien fait
j'aimais bien faire ça enfin quand je le
voyais je me suis dit ouais ce serait
bien de faire ça aussi c'est ce qui est
super c'est quand on dit ouais ça serait
bien de le faire mais qu'en plus on vous
en donne la possibilité de lui voilà
c'est pas toujours le cas ils sont
restés bepa des chèques emploi société
très très haut niveau des de terminale
par exemple c'est leur premier emploi
ils savent ce que c'est que commencer à
travailler il voit la différence entre
le bénévolat par exemple on a les
costumes quand ils cherchent ceux des
costumes quand ils viennent chez moi va
crier les côté visiteur ça c'est du
bénévolat vous voyez c'est pas du
travail mais quand ils sont sur les
lieux un travail rémunéré à la sur leurs
lieux où ils ont leurs oeufs leur
atelier animé là c'est du travail et
jérémy qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
vous passez la la barre alors beaucoup
la barrière et de devenir animateurs
attendent en scène comme thimoté
quand j'étais jeune je voyais toujours
fait
plus vieille que moi qui animèrent et je
trouvais que ça avait l'air assez
intéressant comme
comme travail et je trouvais ça avait
l'air presque un peu amusant aussi quand
on voyait au début d'année parce que
comme le disait thimoté au début de
l'année ya toujours des petits jeux pour
apprendre à occuper l'espace scénique
par exemple toujours très important et
je me demandais ce que ça ferait l'être
vraiment comme de l'autre côté alors
c'est ça alors côté bonne expérience le
plus besoin de tête c'est combien
d'adhérents aujourd'hui et ça s'adresse
donc à une tranche d'âge d'une
soixantaine parce que il ya cinq à six
ateliers de 10 jeunes maximum pour que
ça reste convivial mais j'ai plein
d'anciens adhérents voilà on l'a vu hier
et hier la salle était pleine et ce qui
m'a fait plaisir c'était beaucoup de
jeunes anciens qui revenait voir été sur
la tranche d'âge les cours sont donnés
entre les huit ans à 18 ans avec des
ateliers par rapport à l'âge mais l'ont
énormément d'eux en continu les mains
énormément de jeunes
continuent le théâtre au fur et à mesure
des années et on les retrouve
quelquefois jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin 18
ans ils ont commencé vers huit dix ans
donc et justement quand on commence
comme ça à 8 10 ans ont fait dix ans de
théâtre c'est quoi les bienfaits du
théâtre je doute que ça permet de
prendre confiance en soi d'un énormément
le théâtre c'est pour les jeunes je
pense ça leur permet de s'exprimer de
sortir de leur coquille de s'écouter les
uns les autres parce que c'est ça
surtout citigroup et on les retrouve
après quand ils sont dans un métier j'ai
beaucoup de jeunes qu'on fait qui font
de métier d'avocat de représentants
d'ingénieurs mais qui s'explique qui
savent pas où ça aide à savoir c'est
vraiment dur vous confirmez ça vous a à
vous apporter beaucoup
totalement enfin par exemple aujourd'hui
à un tel point que parfois on surjoue un
peu dans la vie réelle vous avez une
belle voix et rémy je vous avais pas qui
porte à coup ça devient assez amusant à
certaines situations par exemple
aujourd'hui j'avais un oral pour mon bac
et le professeur d'anglais avant que
j'entre dans la salle indie n'en fait
pas trop surtout
s'escamoter oui puisque jean devant un
public on joue devant une scène et ça
nous apprend à parler devant une
assemblée devant des gens qu'on connaît
pas voilà donc ça sert toujours dans la
vie ça vous servira aussi dans votre vie
professionnelle c'est sur la mémoire sur
notre évidemment la mémoire merci en
tout cas vous 3 d'être venu sur le
plateau du journal donc je rappelle que
pour découvrir le travail et les cinq
pièces présentées par le club john terry
et ce jusqu'au 24 mètres à voisins de
bretagne la salle de la tour je précise
au cycle entrée libre mais qu'on peut il
ya une participation un oui elle résulte
est fait au profit des restos du coeur
de trappes les gens viennent ces livres
seul entrée libre mais les gens viennent
avec un paquet de pâtes alimentaires du
café du sud le voilà et il ya deux
grands tonneau qui recommence
tout ça donc en plus à une belle action
belle action voilà les manifs air et
social parti solidaire à faire aussi en
même temps que d'aller voir du théâtre
et je rappelle que nous vaut des pièces
c'est assez varié et du comique il ya
pas mal de polars anciens cette année où
ils ont été choisis par les jeunes voilà
si vous aimez le polar merci beaucoup à
vous trois en tout cas on va poursuivre
cette édition avec un retour sur
l'actualité de la semaine écoulée
et nous avons tout d'abord une page
politique et après valérie pécresse pour
l'ump claude bartolone pour le ps ou
encore chantal jouanno pour le délit
c'est au tour de nicolas dupont aignan
de se lancer dans la campagne des
régionales il sera tête de liste en
ile-de-france elle les explications avec
mélanie poker
pas de surprise nicolas dupont aignan et
le candidat tête de liste de debout la
france pour la région ile de france la
volonté particulière c'est que je veux
qu'on reprenne les cré l'île de france
et qu'on les rende aux franciliens et le
deuxième volonté particulière sur l'île
de france et qu'on s'occupe des projets
concrets a cédé projet mégalomaniaque
moi je veux saut simple je suis maire de
banlieue je veux que rer marche jusqu'à
l'hôpital public ça soit pas le bazar
j'en ai assez des trafiquants de drogue
et jeunes en seine saint denis pour qu
on les nettoie lors des régionales de
2010 la liste conduite par nicolas
dupont aignan avait recueilli 4 % des
suffrages loin du parti socialiste sorti
dans le coeur et de l'ump on dit aux
français il ya autre chose ben c'est
déjà pas mal et c'est un énorme effort
financier un énorme effort de nos
militants pour être présent partout
voilà on va vous offrir autre chose
après c'est à vous de choisir le député
maire de yerres dans l'essonne devrait
présenter plusieurs yvelinois sur sa
liste
la fermeture du centre nautique de mort
pas continuer à faire du bruit
l'opposition socialiste vient de lancer
une pétition elle ne ménage pas ses mots
à l'encontre de la nouvelle majorité est
mélanie poker revient sur ce dossier
nos repas sans piscine c'est non
l'opposition mauritanienne s'organisent
pour signifier son mécontentement
le grief l'annoncent le 4 mai dernier de
la fermeture du centre nautique de la
ville par le maire grégory arrestier le
maire s'appuie sur plusieurs audits et
met en avant la sécurité des usagers on
a fait un audit l'audit du mois de mars
de cette année qui disait qu' il y avait
des travaux à faire à court terme jamais
à aucun moment on a noté que
la population de la piscine les usagers
étaient en danger jamais ça a été mis
dans le alors le dernier rapport la qui
est sorti c'est donc le troisième
là il ne dit pas qu'il faut fermer la
piscine non plus du jour au lendemain
les élus d'opposition il voit plutôt une
fermeture liée à des raisons économiques
les travaux envisagés par l'audit s'il
était engagé se montrer à plusieurs
millions d'euros ce que nous mettons en
évidence ces l'enfumage du maire qui
drapés de la responsabilité finalement
crache son véritable projet qui est une
fermeture définitive de la piscine dans
le but de récupérer un budget qui pourra
servir certainement à financer sa police
municipale ou encore d'autres frais qui
n'existait pas à maurepas et qui l'a
amené mais que dit on déjà été budgétés
le maire les connaît c'est à lui de les
mettre en place mais en conseil
municipal il a refusé refuser de ce
qu'il avait budgété lui même de mettre
les premiers crédits c'est un signe qui
nous montre qu'il ne veut pas d'une
piscine publique à maurepas monsieur van
comparé des politiques publiques qui
sont complètement différente je ne vois
pas le rapport entre la police
municipale et le problème de la piscine
de maurepas j'ai dit aux mauriciens que
je souhaitais évidemment une piscine à
maurepas
puisque les audits sont claires
l'équipement menacent la sécurité du
public j'ai commandé une étude de
faisabilité en concertation évidemment
avec les maires des villes voisines qui
sont partie prenante pour savoir s'il
faut réhabiliter combien ça va nous
coûter combien de temps va falloir ou
s'il vaut mieux détruire et reconstruire
le centre nautique est fermé depuis le 3
avril dernier en cause il corrosion
avancé de plusieurs éléments métalliques
de l'établissement une pétition circule
actuellement sur internet elle est
depuis ce week-end disponible en version
papier elle a déjà collecté près de 700
signatures
le week-end dernier la france
commémorait l'abolition de l'esclavagé
le 10 mai c'est en effet la date de la
journée nationale des mémoires de la
traite de l'esclavagé et leurs
abolitions
et à cette occasion la verrière lançait
son printemps de la tolérance
favoriser le dialogue et les changes
c'est le but du printemps de la
tolérance qui a débuté ce week-end à la
verrière pour la première journée c'est
vers l'histoire de l'esclavagé que la
commune s'est tournée c'est une décision
que l'on a prise il ya déjà plusieurs
mois et qui a été renforcée par les
événements qui sont passés au mois de
janvier qui nous ont beaucoup frappé et
on a donc décidé de de faire en sorte
que le printemps soit un petit peu
symbole de l'amitié et de tolérance est
donc cette journée se rentrer
complètement dans ce cadre là au
programme expositions pour comprendre le
marronnage quand les esclaves prenait la
fuite
lectures de poèmes et contes sur l'
esclavage et vente de produits
artisanaux d'afrique et des caraïbes
de quoi faire découvrir aussi et la
culture africaine
quittant son sa terre natale
n'est pas parti seul
tir on a tué l'homme en tant qu'être
humain on n'a pas tué son esprit donc il
a emmené avec lui sa culture la culture
du coin où il est né la nation on
appelait ça des nations lutter contre le
racisme rassembler et comprendre
l'histoire et des idées apprécié par les
spectateurs le mois de mai c'est le
moins spéciale pour qu'on apporte un peu
notre concours à expliquer les choses
qui sont passés dans l'humanité entre
les hommes de sept sociétaires pourquoi
il ya eu tant de méchanceté pourra y eut
ce commerce
inacceptable et inhumain qui est celui
des hommes des hommes réduits à la
marchandise et puis voilà je me sens
très concernée par cette journée de par
mes origines et puis aussi par
intellectuellement va je trouve que
c'est quelque chose de très important ça
devrait être beaucoup plus diffuse et je
trouve ya peut-être pas assez de
publicité ou deux
danon ce fait à ce sujet là c'est
dommage parce que je pense que là
beaucoup de gens qui seraient serait
venue le printemps de la tolérance de la
verrière se déroule jusqu'au 17 juin
et puis on retourne maintenant sur les
cérémonies du 8 mai les villes de
bonnart 6 à saint cyr l'école et
fontenay fleury se sont associés pour
célébrer la capitulation allemande de
1945 un campement grandeur nature un
campement militaire grandeur nature a
été proposé aux visiteurs
fontenay le fleury 1945 ou presque
bienvenue dans le camp militaire de la
30e division d'infanterie américaine qui
débarque en france à partir du 10 juin
1944 le campement est organisée d'une
manière très définis suivant les cahiers
des charges de l'époque tout toute
l'armée américaine
s'organisait bien précisément et on
essaie de reconstituer en étant le plus
près possible de l'origine dans un camp
comme ça il y avait des cuisiniers y
avait des médecins et à aider des moyens
de transmission on avait lé c'était une
mini ville on va dire donc on trouvait
des cuisines et les hommes pouvaient
manger de la nourriture fraîche et pas
des boîtes de conserve pour célébrer les
70 ans de la capitulation allemande
les communes de bois d'arcy
fontenay-le-fleury essentiel l'école se
sont associés pour proposer trois jours
de fête un peu particulier l'idéal est
très simple c'est de casser le côté
ennuyeux des commémorations c'est à dire
que pendant des années on a eu des
commémorations c'était simplement comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure une simple
cérémonie sous la pluie alors que là
l'idée c'est d'avoir quelque chose de
dynamique est quelque chose de vivant
voilà que la mémoire ce soit plus
seulement ce côté poussiéreux mais
quelque chose de nouveau une quinzaine
de véhicules militaires lourds amphibie
ou char d'assaut étaient rassemblés pour
faire revivre jeunes générations le
quotidien des militaires
c'est très bien ça permet de justement
de pour les jeunes générations de se
rendre compte un petit peu de comment ça
a pu se passer
toujours de se remémorer ces moments là
qui étaient difficiles les commune
yvelinoise ont été libérés entre le 19
et le 26 août 1944
et on termine ce journal avec une note
poétique mercredi dernier était remis le
prix poésie veine 2015 et collégiens une
opération qui a mobilisé très
établissements du département et 450
élèves c'est une auteure in you qui a
été récompensé tu es fait de cendres de
poussière ou témoignera doute en ont
conscience je suis né de l'armée de rêve
des jolis mots lus par les membres du
club jeune théâtre de
voisins-le-bretonneux un texte signé
d'une hauteur innu peuples francophones
du nord du québec rita mestokosho
lauréate du cinquième prix poésie bling
des collégiens l'auteur n'était pas
présente pour recevoir son prix mais
pour l'éditeur français qui a publié son
travail c'est une vraie reconnaissance
l'état s'était aussi s'est aussi appuyé
en faveur des peuples en voie de
disparition
nous est aussi ce qui nous a touchés
c'est ça peut ici est la fois très
simple authentique il ya un côté aussi
très chamanique donc qui parle des
forêts de l'eau du vent mais aussi des
sentiments comme l'amour la haine
l'auteur il nous fait partie des quatre
auteurs sélectionnés pour participer à
ce concours
treize collèges du département étaient
concernés 450 élèves ont tous sollicités
pour lire les textes on apporte ce plus
dans les établissements scolaires de la
lecture d'une écriture contemporaine qui
parlent d'eux qu'ils parlent de ce
qu'ils sont de ce qu'ils font avec un
choix très particulier et volontairement
de livres qui ne sont pas
obligatoirement des livres destinés pour
la jeunesse même surtout pas du tout
destiné à la jeunesse pour leur ouvrir
aussi à une écriture adultes et parmi
les élèves qui ont participé au concours
une classe en particulier s'est
mobilisée la 3e segpa du collège des
soldes guyancourt ils ont travaillé
toute l'année sur un projet d'écriture
autour de l'autoportrait pour ces élèves
en difficulté scolaire la poésie c'est
exprimer ses émotions c'est important
pour eux je pense qu'ils ont du mal à
eux mêmes à les exprimer donc de pouvoir
lire des auteurs effectivement qui
expriment leurs propres émotions que je
pense que ça les touche particulièrement
et c'est vrai que mon a fait lien après
avec les ateliers d'écriture ou eux ont
pu aussi exprimé leur émotion donc c'est
vrai que c'était intéressant
pour eux comme ils sont difficultés
scolaires justement je trouve que la
poésie est plus abordable plus
facilement abordable en tout cas et les
touches plus voilà sur un sur un texte
plus court je pense que plus accessible
j'aime bien quand il parle l'histoire le
hall et rim moi j'aime bien fait comment
elle s'écrie léry
et surtout en fait qu'est ce qu'ils
ressentent on peut voir on peut aider un
peu s'exprimant avec la personne
le prix poésie yvelines est décerné
conjointement par le conseil
départemental la maison de la poésie et
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il dote le
lauréat d'un prix de 3000 euros
selon elle est maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous de
l'information c'est lundi en direct à
18h je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end dans quelques instants vous
avez rendez vous avec le 7-8 week-end
des idées à loisir pour votre fin de
semaine marqué évidemment par la 11e
nuit des musées excellent week-end a
très vite
tous